sie sind die jüngste abgeordnete im
neuen bundestag richtig da habe ich ihn
zum ersten tag direkt eine schultüte mit
gewöhnlich mit den ampelfarben diesem
zeitraum wieso
das ist nach dem ergebnis im sondierungs
papier ist die gestaltet worden
reden sie sich das nur für ein gehen wir
rein
was für ein schönes altes haus in dass
jetzt viele junge leute einziehen die
selber überrascht sind dass sie auf
einmal hier sitzen
wie fühlt sich das so an im bundestag es
ist mal aufregend kennen sie sich denn
so richtig schon aus im bundestag oder
das ist überhaupt nicht
geht einfach mal los und kommt irgendwo
angelegt ich habe jetzt eine hausführung
gemacht aber im groben und ganzen läuft
so ein gefährt en ich bin jetzt seit
drei wochen wegen diesem gebäude
ehrlicherweise glaube ich auch dass
viele von den älteren sich jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen ärgern weil ich
glaube viele junge wurde eben auch
aufgestellt und jetzt auch ein glas mit
sollen diesmal versuchen sieht ja eh
nicht so erfolgreich aus und jetzt haben
wir halt alle so sitzen wir hier mal mit
ich glaube 60 unter 40 und
49 jusos genau das hätte damit hätte
auch keiner gerechnet klar ich meine wir
sind alle angetreten um die welt zu
verändern und stellen dann schon fest
dass die hebel hier ein bisschen kleiner
sind als man so denkt man vielleicht
hofft ich glaube gerade die jugend hat
riesige hoffnung dass wir jetzt wirklich
die wende schaffen und 15 grad konforme
politik machen und am ende sagt uns die
wissenschaft eigentlich es gibt nur noch
zwei szenarien in denen das überhaupt
möglich ist und das schaffen wir mit der
spd und fdp einfach nicht dass nicht
auch irgendwie schön dass sie da sagen
können ich war im bundestag als wir es
nicht geschafft haben die welt zu retten
ich kann ja sagen ich war im bundestag
als wir gerade noch so die kurve
gekriegt haben und ich glaube genau
dafür braucht das hat jede stimme hier
im
plenum also hier ist jetzt ihr
provisorisches büro richtig genau unter
den letzten 50
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich verstehe jetzt warum die spd für ein
recht auf home offices
[Gelächter]
naja also tatsächlich sind das schon für
den bundestag mit der größeren büros
hier wo man sieht der bundestag ist
technisch mit dem neuesten vom neuesten
ausgestattet ich habe gehört wir sind
die erste abgeordnete generation die
jetzt noch reinkommt die kein faxgerät
mehr bekommen herzlichen glückwunsch
danke
also bisher war offenbar faxe gang und
gäbe ich habe aber wie wollen sie denn
dann erreicht werden ja gute frage gute
frage wen hätten sie denn als wunsch
minister oder wunsch ministerin vor den
grünen naja annalena baerbock fände ich
schon alles passen wenn sie
namensgeberin würde welches amt das kann
ich doch jetzt noch nicht christian
lindner hat er schon das kieler
ministerium ins spiel gebracht und damit
der finanzminister werden kann
da kriegen sie keine etwas von mir gar
keine leyen außer
wie gefällt ihnen das wenn christian
lindner finanzminister wird
[Musik]
das war ja auch eine art information war
schon eine art in frage und celli oder
ist schön hier also ich will helfen wir
üben schon mal debatte grüne versus fdp
generelles tempolimit auf 130 km h auf
den autobahnen wir von der fdp setzen
uns dafür ein dass es kein linksrutsch
in deutschland geben wird wir sind das
bürgerliche lager und deswegen sagen wir
dazu nein
gibt es eine begründung für das nein
ja
ja jetzt sitzen wir hier auf dem platz
der fraktionsvorsitzenden wollen sie mal
eine ansage an die fraktion machen
das hat keiner da ja das stellen wir uns
vor
sony wir kolleginnen kollegen bitte zur
ruhe kommen wir kommen zu erhaschen so
läuft das dann keine ahnung so gesittet
ich glaube erde rufen dann die ganze
news rein und dann sagt olaf scholz
jetzt ist mal schluss
whistler gewonnen jetzt ist ruhe und
dann ist es endlich soweit
konstituierende sitzung im bundestag
junge und frische abgeordnete strömen
ins parlament können sie sich noch an
die zeit erinnern als die junger
abgeordneter waren so unverbraucht noch
keine steuer millionen verbrannt ich
komme ich an jeden tag erinnern vor
allem immer wenn ich auf sie treffen ist
es immer einfach immer schön ja frau
klose ist ein junger mensch mit idealen
was ist ihr tipp als
bundestagsabgeordneter wenn sie diese
ideale behalten will außer lauf so
schnell du kannst ja ja nein also hier
gibt es zwei möglichkeiten entweder also
sie verändert den bundestag oder also
sich verändert sich selbst und ja das
hat die
gleichzeitig die gleiche masche nicht
gehört wahrscheinlich passiert mit der
zeit beides ist also ich glaube dass die
vielen jungen leute hier schon auch
schaffen können wenn wir uns anstrengen
auch was bewegen am system wie es läuft
aber natürlich lernt man auch selber
viel dazu also ich habe jetzt nicht dass
die idee ich komme hier rein und weiß
schon alles und bin schon habe weiß ich
dass die weisheit mit löffeln gefressen
so ist ja auch nicht so wir sind ja
schon nach bereit dazuzulernen und auch
von den leuten die schon länger dabei
sind zu lernen also das ist schon mal
eine wichtige ergänzung das also jemand
kommt und nicht glaubt alles schön zu
wissen dass vier jahre geben sie ihr
noch bis das im bundestag dann vorbei
ist das haben wir zumindest lange jahre
nicht mehr gehabt haben sie vielleicht
noch ein paar basis tipps an die jungen
abgeordneten wo kommt man am schnellsten
zur toilette wo ist die beste kantine wo
trifft man sich am besten für krumme
deals mit lobbyisten
also ich würde sagen was hier die ganzen
normalen dinge angeht wie man das
parlament organisiert da gibt es viel zu
tun und auch der witz ich seh schon die
sommerpause hat richtig hier jetzt die
tollsten fabian köster gags produziert
oder sie sind ja schon länger im
parlament erst neu im parlament und was
den anzug angeht hatte direkt einiges
richtig gemacht ich finde ja ich finde
ja da sitzt richtig was sind ich habe
dass die knöpfe das sieht alles gut aus
glaube ich guck mal hier guckt immer das
ist cdu das ist so plastik und das ist
hier das bündnis 90 die grünen ist das
dein vorsitzender auch immer das land
schätzt das ist richtig geil
damit fällt er nicht auf zumindest in
den reihen der union bei den grünen
schon
man sieht die grünen bereiten sich auf
die regierung vor wären sie hier jetzt
nach c&a ja mein nächster tipp ist
informiert dich über die frage wo es was
zu essen gibt nichts ist so schlimm wir
am ende einer sitzungswoche
festzustellen das waren zwei kilo
abgenommen hat weil man nie zum
richtigen zeitpunkt die kantine gefunden
hat vielleicht nochmal motivierende
worte an die jungen abgeordneten im
bundestag holt euch essen
habe langsam angst vor ihnen gehen sie
gehen sie schnell was essen sie sind ja
völlig unterzuckert meine güte
die leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines auto bieten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
los
hast du scheiße fährt haye